>> Dana: TIME FOR ONE MORE
THING.
I'M GOING TO GO FIRST.
THERE WAS A STORY OVER THE
WEEKEND ABOUT THE SYRIA
NIKKI HALEY AMBASSADOR TO
THE U.N. WENT ON THE SUNDAY
SHOWS AND TALKED ABOUT
ADDITIONAL RUSSIAN
SANCTIONS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> YOU WILL SEE THAT RUSSIAN
SANCTIONS WILL BE COMING
DOWN.
SECRETARY MNUCHIN WILL BE
ANNOUNCING THOSE ON MONDAY,
IF HE HASN'T ALREADY.
AND THEY WILL GO DIRECTLY TO
ANY SORT OF COMPANIES THAT
WERE DEALING WITH EQUIPMENT
RELATED TO ASSAD AND
CHEMICAL WEAPONS USE.
>> Dana: THOSE SANCTIONS
WERE ANNOT ANNOUNCED MONDAY
THERE WERE REPORTS IN THE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THAT
THEY WERE PULLED BACK.
LARRY KUDLOW THE PRESIDENT'S
NEW ADVISOR SAID IN THIS
MORNING ABOUT NIKKI AHALEY.
>> SHE WAS AHEAD OF THE
CURVE.
SHE DID GREAT JOB.
EFFECTIVE AMBASSADOR.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN MOMENTARY
CONFUSION ABOUT THAT.
IF YOU TALK TO STEVE MNUCHIN
AT TREASURY AND SO FORTH, HE
WILL TELL YOU THE SAME
THING.
THEY ARE IN CHARGE OF THIS.
WE HAVE HAD SANCTIONS.
ADDITIONAL SANCTIONS ARE
UNDER CONSIDERATION.
>> Dana: IN THE LAST HALF
HOUR I WAS ABLE TO GET IN
TOUCH WITH NIKKI HALEY AND
SHE SAID, QUOTE:  WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT, I DON'T GET
CONFUSED.